yeah the extendo Bro the extendos is a
Surefire way for you not to be able to
run ever in your life again are you
kidding me that's that's nuts dude you
know what their problem is they don't
know what the problem is they think
[Music]
the there's a male escort nice who cut
off serious
tone this is probably the most serious
article we're going Mak it canalyzing it
seems really serious this why I got to
make eye contact with Nick while your
voice dropped like two octaves this male
prostitute hey it's my turn okay sorry s
sorry my bad my bad sh them totally
messed up this intro it's okay it's okay
I I can redo it with I've been here way
too long restart the video can I
interrupt yeah polite guy dude this
guy's polite please I'm three words into
the
article is this m prostitute servicing
men or cougars that's a good question
see you couldn't have kept going without
telling this vital piece of information
um servicing men or man I knew it does
he strip on the side yep cool all right
uh can I continue not cuz I'm homophobic
cuz he's horny cuz there's nothing wrong
with that cuz I want that contact I
think good old Mo again is
because rich men pay more for men I
agree than cougars well they pay more
for young men but yeah yeah how young
like as young as possible Jesus Christ
how young fat a male escort I mean sorry
a male escort nice wow yeah who cut off
a consenting man's genitals and filmed
the procedure for a pay-per-view website
what the has been jailed for 5 years you
go to jail for that wow wow consenting
too I thought this is America
sir so why why probably because they put
on a pay-per-view website in order to
that's pretty wild because of making
content out of it is the part that's
legal oh you want me to write the Doom
for you right now I mean was it like a
publicly known like big website or was a
website that people support separately
is that illegal to show
mutilation like is it illegal like there
I think if you're making content that's
the illegal part but doing it in the
privacy of your home but it's also
illegal if it's an illegal act it
doesn't matter if the other person is
consenting oh like if I go hey you can
kill me if he kills me he's still going
to jail there was a similar case like
this where it ended up being okay but
then when you make the product it's
because that's that's like obscenity
yeah the content
right uh this dude Damien burn I'm glad
I don't get horny off of weird [__] for
real huh when I hear stories like this
I'm like I am I'm glad I'm glad you like
your penis is attached y kind of boring
but yeah Damen Burns age 36 still not
bored with regular porn thank God yet
removed a
penis and testicles with a kitchen knife
back in February 2017 no the kitchen
knife I thought it was just a stem Burns
along with Jacob crimey Applebee age 23
and Nathaniel Arnold h48 pleaded guilty
to causing this with intent uh creamy
Applebee froze this guy Gusto's leg in
dry ice leading to its amputation while
Arnold removed part of a nipple his name
is creamy
Applebees dude it could be crimey apple
by Apple by creamy Apple
pece dude what the [__] is this that's
why I was like wait a minute like we
just going to skip over that creamy
Apple be like is that his sexy name I'm
creepy I'm that's his escort name c r i
m i how would you pronounce that I mean
a lot of screen names are taken nowadays
you know yeah yes cream and then a p p l
e b y Apple bu Apple bu cream
Apple that sounds also weird as F yeah
what is this he was jailed for 3 years
and 8 months Arnold was given a 2-year
suspension uh prison sentence cuz he
only cut off part of a nipple is this in
the US this is sounds like some German
[__] this is actually in London I
believe wow [__] hell they're horny
out there
huh I mean bro who want to be mutilate
wait question they said they put it on
dry ice they put the leg in dry eyes in
order to cut off the amputate the so did
they reattach I don't think
so I mean this guy was consenting to get
and they had dry ice so it was like they
were prepared for this what's that about
this wasn't
like yeah maybe they were just numbing
it not not to like preserve anything
sounds like they're following a really
bad tutorial they're trying to save it
oh they H so so is that a kink yeah well
so so this this the final
King this procedure was technically uh
it was linked to a subculture where men
become quote nolos or short for genital
nullification by having their penis in
test they call them nolos wow so they
can't wait for the day they get it cut
and they call this guy the unic maker oh
[__] so he's done it a multiple times if
he's got a nickname this is not a new
thing oh my God so that's his procedure
he usually the dry ice usually that's
hiso yeah he's the famous Applebees yeah
she told they they said this guy Burns
was hired by Gustafson who called
himself the unic maker and had been
involved in numerous extreme body
modification procedures including the
removal of other men's genitals yeah
dude that's the thing ain't it that's
funny there's a whole like hobby for
everything like he has a following he
has Fame he has a whole group of
groupies that are like cut my dick off
let Matt scroll through the article to
see if he can find some Satanism stuff
cuz I bet there's something attached
this is a kicker this part yeah d dude
yeah that's hilarious um so basically he
readily agreed to mutilate gustavson for
500 lb knowing it would be filmed for
the website but Gustafson reduced the
payment to 50 lb what the [__] y it's
500 pounds to get your he paid he paid
for the procedure huh he paid to have
this guy cut his junk off and then like
we're going to film it okay then you
only have to pay 50 cuz he can make more
money off the back end burn said to
Gustav I have no issue with it but won't
you lose a lot of blood like nearly die
gustavson went on to tell him he would
be an uh [__] I don't know how to
pronounce that it's always hard
anesthetized is that right anesthetized
anesthetized there it is how come it's
not
anesthesiologist that's a good one cuz
that means he would change
careers and tie down and instruct burns
on what to do during the video Burns
could be heard saying well that's one
off the bucket list I never expected
that one how do you pee after that [__]
I think just leak yeah what the f he
can't leak I don't know dude what is
this there's a whole culture around
[__] mutilation and you know maybe it
starts off as like I had a girl step on
my dick and then like later on it goes
to like I just want to get it cut off
but I'm like then that's like the
ultimate but that's crazy that you like
sex so much you cut your dick off isn't
that like you like watching movies so
much you poke your eyeballs out I don't
even know if like it's why would you
like are movies and sex the same it's
the oran it's the oran it's like the
organ for the thing right like you're
you're so horny and you cut off that so
I'm like oh I love the way things smell
so much I'm going to cut my [__] nose
off it's like the it's like the ultimate
uh magnumopus it's like the uh what is
it called for as a masochist it's like
the end all if I do this the most pain I
can die it's
that yeah how about just like being a
foodie or something you know like how
about go to pigs I know like oh I want
the biggest [__] racka lamb the world
has ever seen Raa lamb like I don't know
like talking about Aussies huh the
biggest rack of lamb doesn't come from
the biggest
lamb or the tastiest I don't know you
know and why is it the penis why not the
butthole why don't you like sit on a
cone sit on a cone and sit all the way
down that's been done has it how about
just do a finger there's probably just
some sort of infatuation with the penis
huh
one of the actually one of the gay
homies was telling us that like on
Twitter he follows a bunch of these like
porno like you know Twitter threads like
the gay porn stuff and he's like so much
of it is like
mutilation just like self harm like
there's like a whole Kink to it where
guys will put like electric rods in your
pee hole shock your does he go oh I just
want to see two guys kiss not this oh
man that's a sad thing but apparently
it's like it's a thing that he sees all
the time that is in the community so
maybe this is just the the king
Community the final stage just like what
Ryan was saying it's like that one dude
who like he had an obsession with being
an aput and he was like I just don't
feel like I'm supposed to have arms or
legs cuz he identified as a man so he
took his [__] and he he boiled it
liquefied it put it in a syringe and
started shooting himself up to make his
uh limbs rot off and they did oh my God
and then he would do like he would do
like speeches he's like in a wheelchair
and [__] like f preaching the goodness
of that or I [__] up sh sharing why he
did this cuz so much he wanted people to
literally understand that he was living
with this Obsession that he didn't want
limbs who's the audience [__] Mory
poic baby oh my god oh that's a that's a
good you know it seems to be a whole
thing right now where people don't like
being in their
body always that a thing right now seems
to be a trend I didn't know that was a
thing most people are astral projection
he's talking about it's lit bro you got
to try it that is a thing though people
be like I just want to be tall you know
like that's the that's the normal body
dysmorphia it's like I wish I was taller
I wish my titties was bigger you know
it's like normal [__] level one though
you can't you can't live in I wish yeah
you just got to do yeah they tell they
tell you like I can't grow anymore
though yeah that's what I mean there's a
lot of people that do those surgeries
where they like that's yeah guess what
they're [__] paralyzed now they can't
walk upstairs bro they put the extendos
yeah extendo bro the extendos is a
Surefire way for you not to be able to
run ever in your life again are you
kidding me that's that's nuts dude you
know you know what their problem is they
don't know what the problem is they
think
the we know their problem they don't
they go oh you know why I can't get
girls it's cuz I'm not tall and then and
then they they think that's the problem
right but then every you mean I see what
you mean yeah right right that that they
don't know what the [__] problem is
that's their [__] problem like you're
like hey it's not cuz you're not tall
you never shower you're [__] mean to
people you have a [__] your email
sucks you got a stupid username your
username is like Mr predator or
something your rearview mirror is so
small it's like superficial [__] yeah
you don't have similarities to anybody
you have no bumper stickers on your car
cuckoo is cuckoo man that's cuckoo
classic bro that's true that's cuckoo
classic [__] cucko for CS yeah
exactly it's not even like scientists
are just like why are we studying this
guy he's just
nuts I bet you anything it started off
with his problem not knowing what his
problem is yeah and it spiraled from
there and then it went it went you know
what going to solve this jacking off and
then it went to you know what's going to
solve this a girl stepping on my dick
and then it went to I just maybe not
should have a dick see I I want to hear
from this guy like I want to know what
his life is like post let me let me tell
you a little bit I guarantee you it's
full of [__] trauma so this dude all
right he uh after Burns left he actually
called 999 which is their 911 the court
herd gustavson was treated in hospital
and discharged after a couple of days
with a referral for a psychiatric
assessment [__] yeah I need psychiatric
assessment when Burns did not receive
payment he threatened to go to the
police the court heard Buton responded
by saying he would report him for
threats blackmail and mutilation 50s so
he's turning back around on him 50 bucks
bucks 50 lb smallest of claim over a
period of 2 years Guston paid Burns sums
totally more than 1,500 lb oh come up
okay and then during the tri of the
Court was showing a video of Gustafson
with his leg in a bucket of the dry ice
right gustavson who now uses a
wheelchair receive wait I thought he got
his penis cut off he did then why is it
leg but it's both cuz the bucket was in
dryy ice but now he's in a wheelchair as
well but he received about £8,000 lb in
benefit payments afterwards as well whoa
they're giving him benefits for this act
London is lit bro I bet he had no heal
that is not a service related injury
yeah but they have free health care wait
so this guy had his penis his testicles
his leg and his nipple cut off
basically I think he might still have
his leg 50 lbs he did a sampler I'm good
man oh I like this one I'll get the
other one off he got the mozzarella
sticks the Buffalo eggs yeah I did the
whole sampler baby it's it's it's crazy
but you know what this [__] problem
he doesn't know his [__]
problem just draw this guy his stick
figure and end
the has pain bro dud he looks like a guy
from L of the Rings no it wasn't that
guy either it was uh problem no he's not
in
the other guys yeah oh I don't get no
picture bro Point kid I can't let I
can't see this guy you got join the
patre to see the
[Music]
picture
n